>> I'M INSIDE PYONGYANG'S
BRAND-NEW AIRPORT TERMINAL.
IT JUST OPENED UP.
WE'RE ONE OF THE FIRST FLIGHTS
OUT.
ONLY A HANDFUL OF FLIGHTS
ACTUALLY TAKE OFF FROM PYONGYANG
IN THE COURSE OF A WEEK.
BUT THIS AIRPORT WAS CLEARLY
BUILT WITH THE HOPE AND WITH THE
IDEA THAT THAT NUMBER WILL
PERHAPS GROW.
ONE THING WE NOTICED WHILE
FLYING IN HERE THERE WERE A LOT
OF SOLDIERS WORKING ON THE
RUNWAY.
AND IN FACT, WE KNOW THAT
SOLDIERS PLAYED A HUGE ROLE IN
GETTING THIS PROJECT COMPLETED
RELATIVELY QUICKLY.
THAT'S BECAUSE NORTH KOREA USES
ITS MASSIVE MILITARY AS A
CONSTRUCTION FORCE.
THE SUPREME LEADER KIM JONG-UN
WE'RE TOLD PLAYED A PERSONAL
ROLE IN THE DESIGN AND
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS AIRPORT,
INSPECTING IT, IN FACT, HE WAS
SEEN CONDUCTING A FIELD
INSPECTION AFTER IT OPENED.
REPORTEDLY VERY HAPPY WITH ITS
PROGRESS.
PEOPLE ARE PRETTY RELAXED ABOUT
HAVING THEIR PICTURE TAKEN,
WHICH I HAVE TO SAY IS QUITE
UNUSUAL FOR NORTH KOREA, WHERE A
LOT OF TIMES TRADITIONALLY
PEOPLE HAVE SHIED AWAY FROM THE
CAMERA.
>> HELLO.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> THE AIRPORT EVEN HAS A
CONVENIENCE STORE WHERE YOU CAN
PICK UP A SNACK BEFORE YOUR
FLIGHT.
THERE'S ALSO A SELECTION OF
FRESH FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
SIMILAR TO SOME OF THE GROCERY
STORES THAT YOU SEE AROUND
PYONGYANG.
EVEN FROZEN ITEMS.
ALTHOUGH I'M NOT SURE HOW YOU'D
EXACTLY CARRY THAT ON THE PLANE.
THERE'S ALSO THIS BOOK SHOP
WHERE YOU CAN PICK UP SOME
IN-FLIGHT READING AND OF COURSE
ALL THE LITERATURE IS ABOUT THE
SUPREME LEADER KIM JONG-UN, HIS
FATHER KIM JONG-IL, AND THE
FOUNDER OF NORTH KOREA, KIM
IL-SUNG.
A LOT OF PEOPLE YOU SEE THERE
BUYING THINGS TO READ BEFORE
THEY GET ON THE PLANE.
OUR FLIGHT'S BOARDING NOW SO
IT'S TIME TO GO.
DEFINITELY A LOT TO EXPLORE HERE
AT NORTH KOREA'S BRAND-NEW